سعودي في كييف تاكيد على قدره الرياض على
الحفاظ على علاقاتها مع طرفي الحرب علاقه
مساعده لاوكرانيا وعمل سياسي ودبلوماسي مع
روسيا خلال الزياره التقى وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان بالرئيس
الاوكراني
جلسه مباحثات جمعت الوفدين نتج عنها اتمام
حزمه المساعدات التي تعهد بها ولي العهد
السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان للرئيس
الاوكراني قبل اشهر قليله
وتشمل الحزمه مساعدات انسانيه اضافيه
لاوكرانيا بقيمه تصل الى 400 مليون دولار
منها 100 مليون دولار لتنفيذ برنامج سعودي
اوكراني مشترك بين مركز الملك سلمان
للاغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه ووزاره تنميه
المجتمعات والاقاليم في اوكرانيا فيما
تضمنت الاتفاقيه تقديم مليون دولار على
شكل منحه مشتقات نفطيه جرى توقيعها بين
الصندوق السعودي للتنميه ووزاره الطاقه
الاوكرانيه
الامير فيصل بن فرحان جدد خلال الزياره
دعم السعوديه لجميع الجهود الدوليه
الراميه لحل الازمه الاوكرانيه الروسيه
سياسيا
ومواصله جهودها للاسهام في تخفيف الاثار
الانسانيه الناجمه عنها المملكه حريصه
ايضا
بشكل كبير على
دعم كل ما من شانه الاسهام في خفض حده
التوتر والتصعيد والوصول الى حل سلمي لهذه
الحرب دور سعودي لما يقتصر على الجانب
السياسي او حتى الانساني في الداخل
الاوكراني بل شمل ايضا المقيمين
الاوكرانيين على الاراضي السعوديه عبر
منحهم تسهيلات خاصه لحين انتهاء الازمه في
بلادهم جهود وساطه مستمره تبذلها الرياض
في ازمه اوكرانيا بدات بالافراج عن عشره
اسرى من 50 جنسيات ولم تنتهي بزياره الامس
التاريخيه الى كييف